jk rowling will not feature in the harry
potter 20th anniversary special the
whole cast and crew will come together
to celebrate the harry potter franchise
turning 20 in a hbo tv special to be
shown on january the 1st but the creator
and mastermind of the fictional wizard
boy has been shunned from the show
rowling's reps and warner brothers are
yet to confirm the reason but back in
june 2020 she criticized an opinion
piece that used the term people who
menstruate instead of women tweeting at
the time i'm sure there used to be a
word for these people someone help me
out womban wimphand were mud so has she
been ignored her opinions about
transgender people